ciao a tutti oggi via spezzare la
maggior parte di voi mi avete viste
guide sempre si rispetti lo sapete già
che ho scritto appunto il libro è oggi è
uscito in libreria e neanche disponibile
su amazon se avete già fatto il
preordine non vi preoccupate di arriverà
già se invece non avete tolto potete
ordinarlo direttamente adesso oppure
potete prendere libreria quello qua è
bellissimo è molto più grande di quanto
pensassi per questo si capisce come mai
gravissimo poi un'altra cosa che stavo
iniziando l'altra tonica foto live si
siano fatte di sapere se voi avete
partecipato e che questa parte della
copertina e lucida e nella copertina
faccia e glossy slime si sta benissimo
perché il lucido lucida gloss linificio
insomma se volete prendere libro è ecco
qua le date del film fa topi e quindi se
volete incontrarvi e se volete che sia
il libro appunto che mettano tong
ragionato e queste date quali la con
segnatevi il luogo e l'ora e queste sono
le dato appunto non vedo l'ora di
incontrarvi e apprezzarvi quindi oggi
l'occasione dell'uscita del libro
andiamo fare una ricetta del libro come
vi dicevo nel nostro video di
presentazione del libro se non lo avete
visto poi vi lascio il link in
descrizioni libro non ha solo ricette
slime comunque ricette esclusive o
ricette più classiche ma ha anche una
forza relativa dei fai da te è una parte
relativa a me in cui vi racconto un po
di cose un pò di segreti
questa volta che non di cosa parlano
comunque ne parlo meglio
nel video qui lo presentiamo vinto
comunque se devo provare una delle
nostre sette la fa rossi a io sia vitale
e poi potrete votare se ho vinto io devo
giudicare in base a quale strano bbs di
chi come sempre io sono team azzurro io
di merda alla fine del video vi metterò
quail fondando in cui potrete votare chi
ha vinto in base a quanto mi piace lo
slime è che lei mandiamo a fare oggi
andiamo a fare un live preferito di vita
niente vi do 10 secondi per scrivere nei
commenti secondo voi quale lo slang
preferito di vitale e quello che non
mina sempre lo nomina sempre lo sa in
verde di secondi ma è 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 st
lo avete scritto nei commenti poi
andiamo a leggerli slide cibo potrebbe
essere il tuo film preferito
ma non è il food live qual è il galassie
e partito nominata sempre gas live
io vorrei fare mostre mio padre è
appunto una delle ricette del mio libro
e andiamo subito ad aprire il libro e
seguiamo la ricetta e vediamo che sa
farlo più bello
ovviamente possiamo cambiare magari
colori o i colori dei glitter ognuno può
farne tomba di che colore vuole sempre
seguendo la ricetta babel
eccoci qua
a farci ne ha 70 trovate la ricetta del
galaxy slime e allora sei pronto in
verde al friso frutti
allora abbiamo qua il nostro galaxy
slime innanzitutto che cosa si serve
allora con la trasparente colorante
alimentare brillantini soluzione per
lenti o bicarbonato di sodio oppure
acido borico dipende da quello che usate
voi per attivare lo slime 3 ciotole
abbiamo 4 è stato eletto scuro una
spatola o se preferisce usare le mani la
spatola un contenitore ermetico sarà poi
per conservarlo è un misurino da 15 ml
che sarebbe un cucchiaio praticamente
allora iniziamo con il primo tempo
allora per il primo step dobbiamo
prendere le tre ciotole e mettere tre
cucchiai di colla trasparente in ogni
sotto l'acqua che iniziamo allora che fa
le 18 ma che sono più grandi delle tue
più piccolo perché allora vivo con il
torino da 15 ml ma potete usare
semplicemente un cucchiaio
tieni iniziate grazie allora 3 cucchiai
da 15 ml per ogni gioco loro inizia a
trarsi ok ok allora prossimo passaggio
che dice
versate il colorante alimentare diverso
in ogni ciotola mischiate io ho
utilizzato il blu il viola e rosa quindi
unità storia di rita menu blu il viola
rosa però ora possiamo cambiare i colori
ovviamente potete mettere i colori che
preferite magari vostri colori preferiti
o i colori appunto della galassia della
galassia però questa volta io cambiano
colore
lui si era uno slide sempre galaxy ma un
po diverso come vedete io ancora non lo
so che il colore possa scegliere bene in
effetti blu si vuole il galaxy vorrei
vincere qualcosa di brutto un po di
viola un po di rosa mischiati viola e
rosa di vedere come diventa poi mette un
po di blu dov'è il viola emilia tra
mischiato col nero il trono blu aggiungo
una dozzina o cos'è questo meno per
farlo un pizzico muro messo nero di jolo
un goccino addio comune diventerà
l'isola sta divertendo un sacco mezzo
ros ciao
e poi questo non so di che colore farlo
ci hanno mokarico si fa le stelle non ve
rubare l'idea però è io faccio iniziali
sta mescolando i colori o potete
sbizzarrirvi usare i colori che volete
allora iniziò bicchiere vari colori che
su quelle scrivere commettono vediamo
questo proprio le rosa vediamo
wow bellissimo un viola scuro
no non troppo smog per lui il mio gol e
nero guardo la procura invece mi un po
più chiaro che bello
nel mio più grosso ora vediamo questo
blu e giallo come diventa pensato che
brucia arrivate offerte
quando hai dato mia fatica quando hai
detto io aggiungo del giallo detto meno
però vabbè dai però sta diventando un
verde verde sguardo ai board che bello
blu mi sa che ero forte meglio dai
albero ci posso credere la maledizione
del verde mi sono proprio dimenticata
che non devo rischiare blu giallo
vediamo su un assist ai blu no il nero
con il rosso con il giallo che mix di
colori
io questo bellissimo
guarda questo rosa fucsia invece quanto
è bello bello bellissimo sai perché
posso credere che il bel decreto
risparmi per favore
giordano mentre belle i miei super
scuriscono super attento allora opererà
dialetto facciamo a galassia colorado
certo la grazia è colorato imparando
così bene che è altro che pochi
informeremo vedremo ai sogni e masters
la ride
allora passiamo alla prossima paraben
prossimo step che c'abbiamo numero 3
aggiungete tempi brillantini e mescolate
io ho messo i glitter blu viola e
argentati quindi questa parte super
divertente perché dobbiamo aggiungere i
vari twitter
la nostra scelta sempre verdi veline
abbiamo tantissimi per gli ovviamente
grazie a seguito delle sbronze fi
intermedi cerchi di mentalmente
difficoltà ma il mio slancio la csto per
ritenere utile di melide e io uso dei
glitter dall uso passato perché sla
qualche brillantino carino a invertire
abili nel giallo blu qua anche qua
potete sbizzarrirvi e mischiare vari
colori magari non troppi se non puoi non
sembra più un galaxy ma magari sembra
tipo un click the bomb magari non troppo
dello stesso colore tutti quelli che hai
dato a me cioè vai a quattro tonalità di
verde poi li metto anche un po neri che
sembrano le parole nel cielo tieni
grazie finalmente da qualche brillantino
nel verde ok ora mischiamo il tutto
guardate che bello perché stipic
l'intento mi piace questo è un viola
super twitterato bellissimo guardate un
po che bello questo viola superdrift
rosa ma che cosa ho fatto il bello
l'unione
effettivamente bello galaxy blue guard è
stupendo e iniziamo questo perde con i
glitter neri rossi e la vediamo un po
bellissimo aspetto anche questo non sono
proprio soddisfatto degli colori sono
belli prima lo so ma ho fatto dei
miglioramenti fantastici
sarà per il mio libro perché hai
imparate per stanotte mi sono letto
tutto d'azione diamo quali sono i
trucchetti tutti deve battere io sono
soddisfatto
allora io ci sono piatti tutti che cos'è
quel verde livelli di mango davanti
glitter ha incorporato e poco per volta
un attivatore poi mischiato affinché gli
slide non si addensano quindi dobbiamo
attivarlo separatamente a ognuno nella
sua ciotola esatto bene bene procediamo
possono notare ieri nei commenti mentre
il luogo mi raccomando tre quintali
devo stare attento quando lo attivo
netto proprio poco tre quintali
ok il mio verde è quasi pronto fa strano
dire il mio verde ma non è proprio
perdere a rime a verde petrolio
questi sono tantissimi glitter comunque
quasi pronto lo lascio riposare un
pochino arrivato ad attivare gli altri
nel frattempo anch'io io lascio riposare
anche il mio secondo perché questo
attivando piano piano piano allora vi
faccio vedere il mit dem sono
praticamente attiva
i miei slancio è il mio slight poi
andremo a unire allora questo è il
giallo è molto particolare il colore è
un sacco di stelline e ha dei riflessi
gialli è ancora un po pc cassino perché
non bisogna attivarlo troppo ecco qua il
viola è un bellissimo viola scuro
se stesso con tanti glitter
incollato delitto ed in ultimo è il
verde però non è male questa perde
perché un verde scuro e ha lo stesso un
sacco di glitter per lo stupendo libero
anche questo è un po appiccicosi know
questo molto viola rosa rosa mischiato
al pd sa qualcosa anche questo sempre
appiccicosi non ha portato bello ora
passaggio un numero 5 mettete i tre
slime all'interno di un contenitore
ermetico e lasciate riposare per due tre
giorni vanno messi così allora siccome
noi non vogliamo fare aspettare due tre
giorni li mettiamo in un contenitore
ermetico aspettiamo più o meno un'oretta
e poi vediamo come diventate più
programmi lime quindi abbiamo rosate
viola rosa e viola e poi metteremo anche
il blu qui nell'ambito colore quindi
adesso ti faccio vedere e abbiamo rosa
viola blu
ok che lavora bene e aspettiamo un po
sono proprio soddisfatto comandi che non
vanno messi uno sopra l'altro makoun o
fianco all'altro quindi mystery
nell'angolino schiacciatelo un po poi
facciamo il viola al centro
è il ripetute scuro qua sul lato ora lo
chiudiamo e aspettiamo un pochino allora
numero 6
trascorso questo periodo gli islamisti
saranno uniti tra di loro creando un
unico colore dall effetto sfumato
però noi abbiamo aspettato solo tipo 20
minuti perché non mi mollerà di vederli
per vedere subito quindi aspetta
ovviamente l'effetto non è
super amalgamato super sfumato come se
aspettasse un paio di gioco 12 giorni o
tre giorni in più le bolle non sono
sparite tutte però nessuno e che però è
comunque bello quindi ora ve li possiamo
vedere una alla volta in cui io o se
vince pitale allora siamo incartati
mette in serio dai perché eccolo qua
dentro prima abbiamo aspettato poco
perché non vedevamo l'ora il parco di
vedere allora vedi un po mix di colori
per te ti ho le giallo con tantissimi
che vedete bene le bolle sono in
superficie perché stavano già salendo
allora una volta che si sono amalgamati
colori potete fare un bello sul così li
amalgamate ancora meglio
wow
[Musica]
ecco qua il mio galaxy corte ne pensate
e rimasto leggermente a psicologi ma va
bene non vi preoccupate perché una volta
che lo mischiato fatto il po king e
tutto poi smette di essere appiccicoso e
guardate un po corti glitter sembra
proprio una galassia anche se c'è il
verde in mezzo però alla fine si sta
bene dai un po quante sfumature uomo
d'oro
bellissimo quindi alla fine il colore
una sorta di viola metallizzato con
terre e sfumature gialle e verdi super
estendibile tante bolle bellissima
quella di tante bolle ha quindi ecco qua
questo è il mio ideale xvi ora vediamo
quello digitale
eccolo qui il mio allora come da voi sì
allora come vedete il colore centrale il
viola è stato un po risucchiato dal
rosso sangue molto bello vera dei colori
mi piacciono un sacco
adesso provo a tirarlo fuori e vediamo
un po
estate che bello della proprio
soddisfatto ovviamente sì non è ancora
stato chiaro però guarda che bello i
colori un sistema che supporta unione
degli anziani picchiare il tuo film è
bello ha sbagliato
non ci posso credere che partirà tu sei
riuscito a farlo bene questo caso ho
sbagliato perché lo attivato un po
pochino però vediamo se le statistiche
se maneggiandolo un pochettino investito
queste copie
dovete vedere la forza di vitale conte
cortese questo biscotto e bellissima
strabello veramente marcobello maestro è
stupendo con attività che bello io non
ho proprio contento ho fatto uno slang
davvero un galaxies line meraviglioso
che bene soprattutto contento poi fa
pure i rumori
allora fai un altro futuro ci rimettiamo
a fianco e vediamo la differenza di
colore wow
allora ecco il mio ed ecco quello di
evitare ovviamente lo spir l'edificio
lascia un po desiderare mi è un pò chi
scuro delle stelline e blu allora ancor
più di galassie il tuo viola io tante
stelline veli meglio e melfi contento
che hai fatto fino a giugno sono
riuscito grazie alla tua ricetta sono
riuscito a fare benissimo
finalmente il tuo preferito quindi anche
voleva storpiare adesso prova a rifare
lo swirl ancora più magico più bello
queste legati a una tecnica di euro la
meta è bellissimo so neanch'io
ma è bellissimo ma il esistono nella via
calabria è super spettacolare vabbè ma
che figo sembra una bella città politica
arte capri a capriva camera ha fatto
fuoco allora ragazzi vi lascio poi sul
pazzo in cui potete votare
ovviamente vitale seamus verde
se volete vedere altre ricette dal mio
libro lasciate pure un like su questo
video e vi ricordo le date dei firma
copie così ci possiamo incontrare erano
vi lascio qua quattro cartelle su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri prossimi
video della striscia lenzi i nostri
slime i nostri video divertente su
queste preferite